today we're gonna be comparing American
and Swiss snacks
I am Smith Columbian I kind of grew up a
little bit in Columbia and in
Switzerland I've been here for about ten
years
boring raisins and like just transition
right before school so it's really
definitely known for their cheese in
their chocolate fondue I would eat for
breakfast literally every meet holding
this sounds like the perfect place right
I'm definitely excited to try this max
is my friend me here I definitely wanna
learn more about the culture see what's
up
so these are my favorite snack this is
something you would usually take like
camping um it's very salty I've had legs
before and I think it's a little bit
saltier than later
BBQ chips is just your American said I
put this on my burgers I truly love
barbecue chips well if you like those I
really feel you're gonna like things
yeah
I'm so excited to try this hmm it's
really good these are very similar long
just have like the smoky flavor that
means that doesn't really have I feel
like this would be good on like a burger
or something Oh
[ __ ] burger there we go I could
definitely imagine myself like opening
this bag of chips on my couch watching a
movie and planning world domination
destroying systems if I had to choose
between these two particular things I
would definitely go with this cuz I'm
not a barbecue gal I'm gonna go with
paprika I would also go over here these
are my favorite like forever oh my god
this is a very very very very like Swiss
typical soda no one really has it above
the age of like 20 like Avery don't
really see like older people having it
it's definite like someone having your
mom would pack you it's made out of milk
way
people get grossed out by that and when
you tell them that and they have like
different flavors to but this is like
the original ones like the coca-cola
mm-hmm so this is the coin this is what
every film person drinks can't relate
hey look right at me just get a
SodaStream okay interesting
okay not bad that's not a bad sign the
smell to me is the most amazing thing
ever
mm-hmm smells like malt liquor it almost
just feels like a tiny bit like someone
put in a lemon to your drink and you
just drink it this is like
yeah I wanted to say basic but I don't
know that was me it's similar to ginger
ale but it isn't ginger ale it's
definitely like a really light like
alternative to have instead of like a
coke or something like that I'm assuming
you know what it's amazing this would be
prepared very well with tequila out of
the two I would choose Lacroix because I
feel like it's healthier and like I only
drink water but that's the only reason
for taste wise this this one wins I
think with some really great I call it
face with us
[Music]
well I love this spartax is a vegetarian
spread you either love it or hate it
it's made from potato starch and has
parsley in it people compare it to like
Vegemite for Australia I'm excited to
see what she's gonna take every teen
movie the stoner kind of kid would
always be easy to write from it I
definitely grew up on this it's made
with real cheese but it's gonna need to
be refrigerated so I can tell you a
little bit about easy cheese my mom
would never get it because she's a
Haitian woman so she was like this is
blasphemous for cheese to come out of
camp okay so we have it on toast alot so
I'm gonna spread this for you I'm grant
ready I'm gonna put this on crackers all
right the only thing I don't like about
this is this smell this has a smell this
is definitely smelling this has no smell
I don't know if that's worse oh it's
really hard to swallow definitely is
something at 2:00 a.m. mm-hmm
after a night at the bar not like 6 p.m.
for dinner for somebody boyfriend
parents no not that I think if this was
melted with like nachos good mm-hmm I
wouldn't eat it like this some people
can handle this for it I can't do the
whiz this reminds me of cream of
broccoli soup but it's a spread form
what's really good I don't think I'd
really go for either in general but if I
had to choose it would be this just
because I'm so used to it this will
always be good but I do enjoy the pate
this is chocolate and it has qirush
inside which is a swiss cherry liqueur
red vines so typical standard like
American classic movie theaters baseball
game is definitely something that is
completely recognizable and I'd have
throughout my childhood how many do I
eat so I can feel it in my toes about
that strong these are cute a pack of
cigarettes I don't like these sorry
she's gonna judge my life my story
it's an aggressive amount of liquor oh
wait oh my god he would say these
together I think this comes out to a
shock when you bite into me like that
chocolate shell is very thin that is not
a thick chocolate shell that was all
liquor in my mouth
it's chocolate outside and has like this
little like cocoa powder and then inside
it has like a thing of like sugar melts
like crunching that you feel you like
but I really like these oh is it good
these are kind of like two wolf
plasticky yeah she might be a little
right I think in terms of like candy to
munch on I'd go with the red vines but I
mean like these are better I think I
would go with chocolate I'm Swiss
convert it boy I mean go to Switzerland
mm-hmm y'all snacks would let me just
see how your men's look like and we
might be cooking with something
[Music]